all right
okay elizabeth elizabeth where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
um originally i'm from ohio i was raised
here in clarksburg
clarksburg bridge west virginia and uh
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents as a kid
um my mom and my dad but
my dad was in and out honestly
when you said your dad was in and out
meaning he was you know
he ended up getting put in jail and so
my mom had us for most of the time and
he tried to push himself back in our
life but we didn't really understand why
he left in the first place so
we didn't really want anything to do
with them
and how was life with uh with your mom
uh wasn't really life it was
you know it sucked really good
what kind of stuff was going on um
my mom she was on she was hooked on coke
really bad
and her and her boyfriend started
selling it and everything and
i kind of got involved with it so young
i started using
what age did you start uh 12 12.
did you finish high school no no
how far how far did you get in school um
10th 10th grade yeah and
where'd you go after you left mom's
house um
i got put in i've been
in and out of like foster home and
placements and stuff like that and i got
taken from her
oh at what age um
well the first time i think it was i was
like eight and i got put
in foster home and then my dad got me
out and then that's when he dropped me
off here in clarksburg
he dropped you off he ended up going to
jail for
credit card theft and but he didn't tell
anybody he was going to jail he kind of
just like dropped us off for
thanksgiving and
to my mom so so then what what happened
from there
from there um
it's kind of foggy but um she
just didn't really care she didn't know
how to raise us she wasn't a good mom
but but her boyfriend
um well i grew up you know he's he's my
dad you know i see him as my dad and
he ended up returning to somebody that
i didn't even know any of you certainly
yeah well not not when i was young but
when i got older
yeah he my mom knew about it she
she let me go over there and stuff like
that and um
yeah stuff happened sexual abuse yeah
yeah
so you left home at what what age um i
mean i mean you said you were fosters
you're in the foster system but you were
going back and forth to home yeah well
not yeah and when i was playing with my
mom i ended up getting put in placement
for truancy and then i
then they got i got out of placement and
um
just kept going back and forth and some
stuff happened with uh
more sexual abuse and i had to go
testify and my mom
lied on stand and so i
somebody else like the state let them
take me in and
they end up kicking me out and got put
back in placement
and so so today you're living where um
everywhere you're just kind of drifting
are you are you using drugs as well
which which which is your drug
um nest from ivy user
and what do you do for money now um
i kind of i try to middle man you know
stuff and
sell other people and um
i wouldn't call it prostituting but i
you know more or less
you know and men you know i've basically
flirt with men you know finesse them and
stuff that
help me i mean those are the only people
who want to help me seems like they're
men
yeah and do you have kids of your own
yeah how many kids you have i have two
little girls
and you're raising your daughters no
where are they
um both of them are in the um
foster foster family
do you have any contact with them at all
or no no
so i mean do you have any friends here
on the street
anyone you trust or anyone you're close
to uh
no not no definitely not um
there are um this couple they've
they've helped me out a lot like they're
a big big part of my life
but they're they basically you know they
sell sell drugs too
so it's still a dope game you can't
trust nobody
you've been arrested before yeah for
drugs
no for a domestic and
trespassing
what are the biggest problems or dangers
that you have with this
with your lifestyle um being a 24
year old woman on the streets it's it's
tough
i mean makes me
miss the problem with men and people
saying i can take advantage of you
because you know you're
a female when you're young but what's
what's like the worst thing that's
happened to you
um i've had somebody
shot me they've you know i had to work
up my shot down i'd go mart
and everything now i ended up doing it i
woke up my pants down
and i was laying right beside denmark
i'm sorry
somebody shot you it's yeah i had him
work up my shot and
they basically put heroin and meth in it
together
and shot me out yeah yeah
have you a deed before yeah third time
here
and where i mean do you where do you see
your life going from here you're 24 and
what do you see happening in the next
five 10 years
i don't i don't see anything happen i
don't know what my future
is you know i want better i've tried to
do better but
just the streets just keep i just keep
coming back to it
yeah it's almost like you're addicted to
this yeah yeah
do you do you kind of see the connection
between what happened to you as a kid
and
where you are today yeah
because you know if honestly if it
wasn't for
all of this happening i wouldn't become
the person i am today and
i'd probably it'd probably a lot worse
if everything didn't happen this way
i could be dead or something else but
you get depressed
oh yeah you've been suicidal before yeah
yeah
what kind of stuff have you considered
well i've i had to get my stomach pumped
once for
i took like a whole bottle my seizure
medication when i was younger
my mom watched me grab the bottle out of
her
cabinet and she asked me what i was
doing i told her and
students started custody and everything
and i went to bedroom and
she walked in and from there it's blank
i woke up three years later in hospital
have you considered like getting a
therapist and
talking with that i've had their
therapist all my life
and i don't see talking to somebody who
hasn't been through what i've been
through
you know helpful at all i feel like
they're judging me
what was the worst point of your line
now right now
i rather relive everything i did as a
child well
it's bad to say to do what i'm going
through now
but if you had like two parents that
loved you and supported you and all that
you
you feel like you'd be in a different
space right
if i had two totally different parents
yeah
in some ways it's almost like you're
repeating the cycle
oh yeah every day i wake up i wonder
where i'm gonna lay my head
how i'm to get money to you know feed
myself the days i go without eating not
because
you know i'm on meth but because i can't
afford to eat yeah
you ever been loved before yeah
is this lifestyle can i get in the way
of that
well me being homeless not really having
anything yeah
what do you think what do you think
would help you the most right now
if someone just helped me and
not doubt me you know people down means
worse
because it gives me in my head where i
feel like i can't
i know i can do better
because i don't see a point in trying
to get better and trying to if i don't
really have anything to live for
and losing your kids is going to set you
back right is that what gets you the
most
yeah it's going to be hard
and then the your unstable
housing is is got to be difficult to
deal with too right
oh yeah if i if i had my own place
i definitely wouldn't it wouldn't be
like this i mean
i just want to be able to i don't know
the last time i laid in a bed
where do you typically sleep with
crystal meth you don't sleep
well i mean eventually you have sleep
yeah but
i do kind of just
usually it's you know a guy's house i
have to stay at it i'm too scared to
fall asleep
but when my parents you know they
they're not my real parents but you know
my street parents you know they have
their own life to live too i can't
go there and you know
sleep whenever
you have any dreams or anything that
you'd love to see happen for yourself
are you just trying to survive
both i mean i want i just want to have
be able to have something of my own i
want to be able to say i accomplished
something
and you know something good instead of
but yeah i'm just trying to survive
yeah there's a lot of shame in this
right you feel guilty for losing your
kids you feel guilty for
some of the things you do right well
yeah so i i should have
you know known the way i grew up with my
mom you know
you know i assumed i had my kids like
yeah i know what to do i know how to
raise her
and everything and
i never what do you think it is
you think it's just that your self-worth
gets set at a low point because of what
you went through as a kid
having the mom you did having your
stepdad that
kind of in a way it makes me like like
stronger
but like with all my i have a lot of
mental issues
and that kind of gets in the way that
got in the way of my you know me being a
mother and
everyday life
what's the hardest part for you
being alone not having not
knowing that there's nobody that really
cares nobody
all right elizabeth thank you so much
for talking with me and
i wish you luck getting your in your
life together
thank you you could use some nice breaks
thank you
you